Blake Lively goes red isn't that sexy
isn't it amazing yeah the actress was
spotted rocking a fiery new do on the
set of her movie it ends with us we've
got lots of colors and lots of sides to
us she's wearing a long brown dress
paired with penny loafers transforming
into small town college graduate lily
bloom for the film adaptation of the
best-selling novel which became a book
talk cultural phenomenon this is true
Blake star's opposite Justin baldoni
who's also directing and this first look
at the actress in character has fans
hyped for the movie's release oh that's
nice
when she's not on screen Blake's taking
on the role of mama she shares four
children with husband Ryan Reynolds you
know you'd have to be a to do this
four times if he didn't like it who told
ET last year just how much he's loving
fatherhood I just love being home with
my family and you know taking the kids
to school I have so many other aspects
in my life that keep me busy and it
seems like you've been busy with the
friends friendship bracelets too oh yeah
my daughters love to love to make Daddy
bracelets yeah they're probably tracking
devices actually now that I think about
it truth be telling them Blake's also
taking some time to focus on Mom duties
my family is my priority and I'm
fortunate to have a job where I can take
my family with me and I can
tailor that
um but um but I I hope that my girls
always feel what a priority they are and
see that they can be professional strong
powerful women she recently skipped out
on the med Gala despite being a staple
at the annual event for years but
there's no doubt she's imparting some
fashion wisdom onto her kids do you now
that you're a mom do you take like looks
and keep them and maybe want to pass
them on oh now I've done it always like
since I've been 16 I'm like my child
will love this piece from Forever 21 one
day that's just like falling apart but
it's uh you know that's why I'm I'm
happy to have had a girl because I have
a lot of things I've been hoarding with
the excuse to pass it down
foreign